pour prier avec le pape jean paul ii
abrité par un parapluie a longuement
porté une autre croix de bois
s'arrêtant 14 fois pour marquer les 14
stations
symbolisant la passion du christ à
chaque station
le récitant visait les passages de
l'évangile et des textes de catherine de
sienne
l'une des grande mystique italienne de
l'épaule de la ferme essence et après
chaque récitation la foule des fidèles
entonnaient le stabat mater en latin
après la dernière station le pape dans
une homélie a lancé un profond appel à
l'unité et il a donné la liste
douloureuse de tous ceux qui de nos
jours encore souffrent au nom du christ
ce soir le pape prend part à la liturgie
du feu nouveau à saint pierre avant de
célébrer la messe de la vigile à
beyrouth le cessez-le-feu était une
nouvelle fois rompu par des tirs
sporadiques en plusieurs quartiers de la
capitale
le patriarche de la communauté maronite
d'antioche et de tout l'orient
monseigneur boutros corbett a invité ce
matin tous les libanais à s'unir autour
des autorités légales libanaise facteur
d'unité et planche de salut dit il
comment les chrétiens du liban ont-ils
vécu le vendredi saint philippe rochot
s'est rendu à l'université saint-esprit
à kaslik chez les moines maronites en
plein centre de l'enclavé contrôlée par
les critiques
oui
vendredi saint au liban était placée
cette année sous le signe du deuil
nous sommes à l'université du
saint-esprit à kaslik chez les moines
maronites au coeur du liban chrétien sur
les premiers contreforts de la montagne
les chrétiens de beyrouth en raison de
la menace d'une reprise des
bombardements syriens sont venus
jusqu'ici pour célébrer cette fête avec
les quelques 200 g maronite qui enseigne
la théologie dans cette université
c'est le seul établissement qui n'est
jamais cessé de fonctionner même pendant
la guerre civile des chrétiens du liban
en ont fait un symbole celui de l'heure